[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the public
space today we will be speaking with
bill gayde about the concept of energy
are you doing bill good all right so
just before we jump into it a couple of
updates for the crab look at what I've
been creating I've created a beautiful
corner of tiles for Mama Jeff for the
wooden stove so that I can keep her warm
for the winter with a beautiful tile
pattern here that includes glass mosaic
as well as just normal tiles up and down
absolutely safe it is resistant to heat
so it will be perfect for my wooden
stove I'm so important in the news many
channels on YouTube have been gone
including unfortunately James aza so we
lost James ours up we also have American
identity movement little revolution two
TRS radio V there it seems that the
people who have been targeted by the ADL
in a blog post a week ago five of them
are gone today people would remember
also that way of the world and and other
channels are gone so so we're at at
least seven channel that I've been gone
please join these creators including
James aza
go check out is Gabe comm go check out
this bit shoot they it's it's where they
will be able to update you guys about
this situation all right bill get we got
some energy matters to be discussing so
you've been nice what today's energy day
right yes either you are very energetic
so energy and at the same time it's
great that we're talking physics that it
may allow me to survive this wave of
censorship maybe
maybe get one of my video of the week
not demonetised oh yeah by the way join
us on entropy this is my favorite
platform for super chats entropy the
link is in the description below and we
have a poll today to test the reactions
of the crowd to Bill's IDs the poll is
is energy just a whole [ __ ] concept
[Laughter]
it will populate with the audience
opinion on energy so let's get started
you've been critical of the concept of
energy before on this show how how does
it work what is an energy first for
physicists and why are you triggered by
it first I think if I may I want to
cover just very briefly a tangential
subject which is the issue of black hole
okay
last time we adjourned and there was an
issue with the black hole and I wanted
to clarify that because it's gonna
relate to what we're gonna discuss today
and the issue was whether a black hole
crushes all matter out of existence if
you look at that number one gift well
the pick that I sent you
yeah that one there it says black holes
are the most exotic objects etc etc and
you can see that professor Cole Miller
says all a black hole is crushes all
manner out of existence so does
professor David Harrison they say that
all matters crushed out of existence but
they are I mean the traditional concept
of black holes is not crushed out of
existence the matter still exists but
it's stuck in a region of space-time and
all it can do is affect the rest of the
universe by its matter affect it's
gravity affects right no
it's not right if you look at the other
two number two there if you look at
number two it says this comes from
Stephen Hawking is a brief history of
time and he talks about Chandrasekhar oh
I didn't know that Stephen Hawking was
black I thought he was what yeah but he
changed color anyways tender
Chandrasekhar got a Nobel Prize for
saying that a black hole collapses
completely to zero dimensionality and
there is no matter that's what he got a
Nobel Prize for so if you look at that
he explains that he says Eddington was
shot Eddington was Chandrasekhar his
boss essentially right says Eddington
was shot by that implication the fact
that you got infinite density and no
matter and he refused to believe
Chandrasekhar's result Eddington thought
it was simply not possible that a star
could collapse to a point this was the
view of most scientists Einstein himself
wrote a paper in which he claimed that
stars would not shrink to zero size and
that's what he got and then he continued
saying that's what Chandrasekhar got the
Nobel Prize for for showing that matters
crushed completely out of existence
there is no more matter left all we have
is infinite density and in zero value
and then if you look at number three
there we have a from 2012 this this is
from a formal paper that was published
you see the reference there and said
Leonard together with France Pretorius
of Princeton University showed that the
point where a small smaller black hole
pinches off from the screen the black
hole radius is zero which means its
density is infinite and if you go to
their paper the one on the bottom letter
and transport Oreos they say the
everything string regions and been
strengthened 0 sides revealing a
massless naked singularity
so yes the official words I mean people
out there might have different opinions
but I'm just telling what the official
version of math
physics is and that is all matter is
crashed out of it crushed out of
existence if the black hole is at least
one and a half times are up to three
times as much as Sun come in a couple of
Rose positions here I think it's it's a
more common position by a physicist than
you make it to be this idea that the
singularity is just a mathematical
singularity and that we still don't know
if there's a physical singularity in
fact a lot of physicists believe we will
have some law that we will eventually
discover which would explain that the
thing is not truly zero size that's one
thing the other thing is also the our
King's radiation our King's radiation
occur and therefore and I think most
physicists accept this and they would be
a sign that the matter has not been
pushed out of existence in fact it comes
back into existence at some point in
time in the future the issue here is
that what you're saying when you're
saying that it comes back into existence
in other words the black hole somehow
spits this matter back into the universe
they're talking about not the
singularity they're talking about the
event horizon they're saying that you
know here if this is the event horizon
is the region of influence of the
singularity of the black hole and that's
what they always draw as a circle and so
when you're talking about Hawking
radiation you're talking about what
happens outside of that region of
influence which again is is just like a
campfire you got the campfire you have
the region of influence of heat and the
event horizon is a region of heat of the
black hole the singularity that's what
you got imagine it it's yes spiracle
budget but the singularity is losing
mass when the our Kings radiation occurs
and so there's a philosophical view in
which the black hole is emitting
something back into the universe I mean
I just wanted to point that out
people are pointing out on the regular
chat they say what is Bill drink
what's this crazy straw but yeah because
people believe the black hole on the
base is about Authority oh no deliberate
there's no now into the black hole first
of all second all mathematical
physicists they'll tell you that they
cannot explain how the universe works
they cannot give you a physical
interpretation or they're gonna give you
one in they're gonna say well that's not
important that's philosophy what we care
about is the math equations that's what
they'll tell you because they cannot
make sense of what they're saying
there's no way all right no my comments
was literal people want to know what
you're drinking it's a literal question
this is ma T drink annoyed in South
America we drink my tea okay like I I
was telling a j-f minute ago that this
is not a drink it's not a tea you know
what it is is an excuse you tell someone
you know you don't say to someone hey
you know we're gonna do business on
Saturday now what you say is why don't
you come over and we'll have some mati
and that's the excuse that's the reason
you're getting together
you talk about girls football and of
course the business at hand right I
can't believe that there's a culture out
there that finds work so repelling that
they need an excuse to get to work it's
like if I want to work with you I'm
gonna say bill I want to work with you
on Saturday I don't need to say violet
that's that's violence violence is a
lazy guy who wants the tea alright so we
have our introduction about black holes
so black holes in this conception fall
to zero sighs yeah and so the issue with
energy is that it's a word used by
mathematical physics essentially you
know and it's never been defined you
have I think I sent you the reference
there and it's number
which one would that be see if I can
find it here it's a six well I can't see
it now but anyways there's one of the
reference there that I sent you and it's
got to do with which is named a richard
fineman i think it's the last one or the
next of the last one one of those two
it's fine man yeah it's yeah yeah if you
look at that at the top he says it is
important to realize that in physics
that they we have no knowledge of what
energy is so that's the definition of
mathematical physics of what energy is
what energy is is a is like the Joker
and a rummy game that you can put any
time you need you know it's just the
spirit it's another word for spirit in
traditional religions they would say
what move the curtain and they would say
it's the spirit you know the spear of my
grandmother or whatever and today they
say no now that's religion how can you
say it's a spirit no its energy yeah
what have they said they haven't said
anything because energy is defined as
the capacity the capacity to do work and
the capacity is not a physical object
but if you look at that reference I sent
you there which one is it
number five is it no number six sorry
this one yeah number eight sorry go go
to number eight all right right number
eight I don't know if you can do the one
with sound which is the mp4 yeah I can
do that one okay do then number eight
the other one the one that has sound
behind it okay so the the video you want
to watch a video if you show that that'd
be great
okay there it is so I don't know if
you're gonna hear the audio but if
there's a new our crowd will hear it
yeah I'm not hearing the audio oh you're
not that's the mp4 yeah okay well
anyways what the guy is saying what I
wrote there okay he says that everything
is a bundle of energy that comes out of
this tiny thing and and then he is says
at the end what you're looking at what
you're seeing is energy and so on the
one hand that you find it is the
capacity and now here you can see they
says what you're seeing is energy that's
what the guy says that's the official
version everybody imagines energy like
some smoke or some halo out there right
and there's no such thing because energy
is defined as the capacity the capacity
to do work so it's a concept and you
can't point to a concept you can't say
oh that's energy because it's either an
object or a concept you can't have it
both ways God cannot be an object a
human with hands and at the same time be
intelligence of spirits love those are
concepts God has to choose if he's gonna
be loved he can't be a human being and
energy has the same problem energy
cannot be a physical object here and a
concept that is defined over here if you
define energy as the capacity you cannot
say I'm going to point to the capacity
that's the issue it's people don't like
to deal with that but it's an important
question of language because they're
using a concept to designate an object
that's the issue I agree with you that
energy is not an object and in fact it's
a concept that that assumes the link be
often between two forms of energy and
it's transferability and within this
energy just plays the role of transfer
and of capacity to that being said that
these capacities are located in space
there it is located because there are an
object the object is what's located in
space you can say the the Apple is in
space and the Apple has this capacity or
whatever energy is but you cannot say
I'm
- energy energy is in space that's
irrational because you're saying love is
in space that's what you're saying
all right so where does that get us well
they give us to one of the key words of
mathematical physics what is this word
energy the other one is the word I
mentioned at the beginning mass because
mass is another form of energy energy is
a form a different form of mass
according to Einstein's equation which
actually wasn't his either but that's a
separate story the point here is they're
using all these words which are concepts
don't you find this concepts first of
all second they're undefined concept
because mass has not been defined they
have several different types of mass two
of them alone for a special relativity
you have inertial mass and you have
relativistic mass you know they have all
these words which they use ad hoc they
use it as needed at a given point right
and essentially they're undefined or
they're defined as concepts and then
they treat them as objects they're gonna
say I'm gonna lift the mass I'm gonna
transfer the energy I'm gonna bend time
what do you mean you're gonna bend time
what the hell is that they say well
you're not supposed to take the analogy
literally but then what the heavy said
what is the physical interpretation how
can they say that time you unite it with
space creates something called
space-time when both of them are
concepts you're uniting a concept called
time with a concept called nothing and
you have time and nothing one second
plus nothing and that equals the
space-time in which we live
what sense does any of that make its
irrational completely you cannot
understand mathematically you cannot
understand the physical interpretation
of mathematical physics that's the point
all right so where do we go from there
well we have to get rid of all the
language we mean we have to ask this is
where I start I say we have to ask what
is physics what is science what are we
trying to do here and I'm saying we're
not trying to do math for sure and I'll
give you a for instance if you allow me
to someone comes over and breaks your
window right they threw a brick through
the window or
or your neighbor hates you and he went
with a crowbar and just broke your
window do we need any mathematics do we
need to do any experiment to prove the
mechanism no someone just shows you and
says look your labor came over with a
crowbar broke the window we all
understand that why we understand it
because we can see all the objects we
can see the crowbar your neighbor the
window the glass on the floor we imagine
all of that you don't need to explain to
me the mechanism and say I'm gonna run a
test to verify your theory now you don't
need to do any of that because here's
one theory it says a crowbar broken
another guy says no the baseball went
through the window no guy said no it was
a prick okay fine there's different
theories but you can imagine all of them
because you can see all the objects
what's happened we can explain all that
so we can explain an inclined plane you
know you roll a ball down an inclined
plane it goes down we all understand
them because we can see all the objects
how did the pail go up we can all
understand that because you've got the
pulley you pull on the rope it goes
through the little old wheel and pail
comes up out of the pail end up there we
can all explain it because we can see
every object the problem we have today
we have no explanations for the
invisible workings of mother nature of
father universe we don't know how the
cosmos works the invisible part of the
cosmos we don't know how mother nature
works in her invisible day-to-day
operation she we don't know how she does
magnetism we don't know how she does
electricity we think we do we we don't
know how she does gravity and it's the
invisible stuff for which we have no
explanations today and here you know I
always do a very simple experiment that
all of you can do always in the presence
of a train relative okay here I want you
to watch okay I've got two little
magnets there can you see those yes
these little circles there okay they're
two magnets okay I'm gonna put them
together and they stick together okay
now do I need to go to the University do
I need to do any mathematics any
advanced calculus or linear algebra do I
need to do any experiment in the
to show the mechanism of how this thing
attracts that because no one can explain
the simple thing today and it turns out
this is the simplest thing it's it's
just like the inclined plane
it's just like the pulley the only
difference we can't see the mediator and
so the irrational folks who do particles
which is 99.99% of the universe today
they say well there's two mechanisms
that they come up with two mechanisms
using particles one is that you remove
the particles between the two magnets
and the particles on the outside here
they push them together that's one
mechanism it's known as Lesage or
castamere really both of [ __ ] because
Gassendi was the guy who did that in
1644 he wrote about it Pierre Gassendi
French guy okay anyways that's one
mechanism
what's the other mechanism the other
mechanism is what quantum invented and
this was more irrational still and it
says what this one is doing is the the
other one here is throwing negative
momentum particles of the red one so it
delivers negative motion and you know so
you got a negative force and it pulls it
in because you're delivering negative
momentum in math that makes sense
because all you have to do is put a
negative sign you're done but in physics
you know yeah you cannot even imagine
that how can you send a negative
momentum so you cannot explain this with
particles no matter how you put it and
twist it and turn around you cannot
explain this with particles and for sure
you cannot explain it with weights so
the question is you know we don't have
an answer for this because we're still
we still cannot answer specifically the
force of pull the force of pull does not
exist in all of mathematical physics it
doesn't exist for gravity and it doesn't
exist for magnetism it doesn't exist for
anything so the only problem is the
force of cool even the even if you go
with you know with quantum mechanics you
have the quarks that form part of the
nucleus in other words part of the
proton or the neutron either when you
have these pre quarks right what pulls
them together they say well it's gluons
so what is it
blue what is a particle so you're
throwing little stones from one part to
another and they pull each other
together how can you imagine that you
know it's it's irrational and again the
only issue that mathematical physics
hasn't been able to resolve in the last
500 years is the force of pull it
doesn't exist in all of mathematical
physics it only exists like if you're
pulling on a dunk right then you say
well yeah you put a cord at a rope
whatever equal and the dog but these
guys are explaining the invisible world
of mother nature gravity magnetism all
these things and they're saying look the
way you pull on a donkey is you throw
stones at it and that's how the donkey
comes towards that's quantum mechanics
in a nutshell and nobody can imagine
that it's irrational but everybody
accepts it on the basis of Authority
only because it comes from can bridge or
heart I always taken issue with this
part of your theories because it seems
that you're appealing to intuition okay
by intuition throwing stuff at something
else will push it away from me but this
doesn't mean that all universes and that
the particular universe in which we live
doesn't allow for other types of pushing
what gives you the sense that our
intuition must be right here we have to
rationalize if I'm gonna explain a
theory to you a mechanism I have to
rationalize it for you and if I cannot
rationalize it for you if I cannot
rationalize pull or I rationalize it
with particles and say look you know the
subatomic world works different and the
way it works is that you know particles
go out and they draw things together
well all I'm doing is introducing
spirits that's all I'm doing I'm doing
magic I'm doing witchcraft because no
one can imagine that for the subatomic
world you know if you're gonna explain
something to someone in a rational
manner it's it's you can say it's
intuition but you know I can explain to
you a mechanism that you can understand
if you're gonna accept the mechanism
proposed by quantum mechanics saying but
we're gonna throw negative
momentum stones and that's gonna bring
it towards you but you know you're
accepting an irrationality only because
you're insisting on particles there is
no proof of the existence of particles
the particle is an assumption keep that
in mind and you know how you can prove
that to yourself you want proof here's
proof you go to the standard model
you'll see at least 12 particles there
and you won't see the picture of any of
them we've never seen a subatomic
particle period we're done because if
they see Monday with draw a picture of
one days table look this one looks like
a smiley face this one looks like a
letter age they're beings or whatever no
they don't have any idea what these
particles look like they just put the
name of it a Higgs a an electron
whatever and they say it's a part where
did they get that because they think
they're accelerating particles that
because they proven it they've always
assumed that what they're doing is
accelerating discrete particles that's
the issue I think the de-emphasis of
particle is an interesting thing that
could happen in the future because the
more we talked the more I abandon my
concept of particles and the more I
believe in in quantum fields so I think
that particles are partly essentially
understood in terms of the excitation of
a quantum field at the located position
in in space such that it's enough to
trigger a detection event in other words
is it possible to see particles as just
the the threshold activation of a
quantum field to its detectable state
I'd love to accept that if I knew what a
field was see the word field was
invented by Michael Faraday he's the guy
who used that he's the guy who created
it he used it in several of his
presentations at the what is it the
British I can't remember this thing well
anyways where he gave his presentations
anyways he would give his presentations
he would use the word field which is the
best word he could imagine for the
region or
the magnet so he would say look you know
magnet has this field around this region
where there's something going on which I
don't see which I can't imagine what it
is something is going on there I'm gonna
call this a field so we don't have a
word we don't have a definition for the
word field other than the fact that
today from a mathematical point of view
it's just a bunch of values around an
object so if you take a ball any ball
you know for example right if you take a
ball and you have all these values it
could be gravitational values they could
be electrical values magnetic values and
they said look at this this ball this
metal ball or whatever you got there as
all these values around it so and we can
measure that those values we can measure
the strength of the field at each point
in space around the ball that's the
point but then you say well what's the
field and they don't know they just they
just tell you it's just a bunch of
values around an object that's the issue
the issues there's no physical object
called field and that's another of the
words you have charged field time mass
energy force none of these words have
ever been defined and if they're defined
or defined as concepts not as objects so
you cannot say that a particle is the
vibration of a field because there's no
physical object called a field you're
vibrating love and saying oh I got a
heart no no a heart is not a vibration
of love and that's what we're saying
with the word field there is no such
word as field not in science it's it's
the word field is part of religion
anyone who uses the word is in religion
there's no there's no such concept in in
physics there's no physical standalone
object called field well I mean this
whole religion critique couldn't we say
that by asking by imposing the idea that
we need to talk of objects and not
mathematical property and fields you
have your own religion they'll get in
the end yeah but my religion has to do
with objects I can explain my religion
because you can see all I can make a
movie of my theory I can show objects up
there on the screen you can look at you
can watch the movie and say okay I
understand your theory not that you
believe it it's that you can understand
it because just
like the inclined plane and the and the
pulley and all this you can see and
understand what I'm proposing you can't
do that with quantum mechanics you gotta
go what you just said you gotta say well
the quantum world works differently
that's all you can say but you cannot
visualize the explanation the physical
interpretation that quantum or general
relativity gives you their equations
that's the issue and I'm using the same
equations I have no problem
Schrodinger's equation for example for
quantum mechanics but but you can see
what I'm saying you know you know you
can see on the screen what I'm proposing
you can look and say okay I understand
what he's saying but you believe it or
not that's a separate issue but at least
you can see what I'm proposing you can't
do that with quantum mechanics there's
no rationalization of the physical
interpretation all right we we have
people telling me that entropy was down
for a moment I've just reactivated it
sorry for this it happens every night it
seems we have a couple of reactions from
the crowd let's have a look at this so
what do we have here we have a question
it says physicists have used energy to
define both the physical movement of
electrons and a concept should we derive
new definitions or concepts to separate
these well what we need to do is get rid
of the word energy because it clouds
more than what it clarifies what we have
to do is find out what physical object
is doing capacity doing energy then we
can you know we got to visualize mother
mother nature's universe we got to sit
back and do what is known as armchair
physics that's the real business because
physics is useless for anything if
people say well what use does your
theory have I can't can I go to the lab
and create a new device can I invent
something with it no physics is useless
for anything we don't use anything we
don't use physics for any all we do with
physics is try to understand how mother
nature runs her shop that's all we're
trying to understand how the universe
works that's it and so we sit back and
we try to visualize
okay we're trying to think we're using
our brain we're not going to use our
hands we're not going to use our eyes
we're not going to use our smell or ears
none of that what we're going to do is
use our brain we're going to use our
mind we're going to sit back close our
eyes and say how does mother nature do
magnetism how does Mother Nature to
krabi that's what we're trying to figure
out and the way you do that is not with
math we have no use whatsoever for math
all equations ever invented have no
purpose in physics in genuine physics
which is just figuring out the
mechanisms that mother nature uses how
she does her tricks and for that you
just sit back you aren't your physics
you think and you try to visualize how
she could be running all these invisible
things that we can't see
I would like to reconcile you with maths
so suppose I take the bill gayde theory
of physics and I accept the ropes and
that's how it works and we were pretty
certain that that's how it works there's
still a possibility where you could have
F equals MA in your physics
you could have mathematical description
of what's happening is there something
wrong with math all over or what is the
problem here
the problem is that science and it's
it's one of its branches physics has
nothing to do with math math is a
description math can only describe math
has no power to explain anything
I agree six is about explaining and so
now we have a contradiction because if
math only describes and physics only
explains then there's no there's no
match this doesn't mean that we we
cannot explain why we have the equation
F equals MA
I can explain very clearly I mean I have
explained Newton's general gravitational
equation also and I do that all I'm
saying is that we got to separate the
two
I can explain the equations I have I can
justify those equations from a physical
point of view that doesn't mean that
we're going to incorporate now
mathematics into physics and say
mathematics is it stands in
the equation standing knew of physics no
way
math is math physics is physics you have
no such thing as mathematical physics
that's where the problem is where we try
to unite these two math should stay as
math you want to do equations you want
to do relations between variables that
you measure fine that's great
that doesn't mean that that's physics
physics is explaining the mechanism how
did the window break I have no use for
mathematics I don't need to use the word
force the word energy show you how the
window pro all I can say is the brick
went through the window that's how it
broke and you understand the mechanism
right there now you don't need to know
energy you don't need to know force you
don't need to know how much how many you
don't need to measure anything you need
to notice how did the window break what
was the mechanism a break once we win
period we're done but it's also no it's
great to know the details and the sense
you recognize the world of mathematics
in describing utimately any physics will
be describable using the language of
math yeah yes no problem
but again description is not science
science is explanation that's where we
have the problem and what I'm what I'm
proposing is that at least since the
21st century we have a new version of
science and of the scientific method
that's when I'm proposing and and we
have a paradigm shift and it doesn't
mean you have to accept it but you
should be aware that we have a paradigm
shift in the word science and in the
what we call the scientific method
because rational science because
rational scientific method to
distinguish it from what they've been
doing for the last 500 years since
Newton and Galileo and so on all right
mr. Pfister you have a new good
was there anything no no I was just
saying that again there's been a shift
and it doesn't mean people have to
accept it but people have to ask this
question to themselves if they're honest
with themselves and they should ask what
is physics about what is science about
what are we trying to achieve are you
interested in understanding
how a magnet attracts another or are you
just going to describe it forever and
say well this is the four this is how
many Gauss are involved here I mean
that's a measurement great and so you
know how strong a magnet is you know all
that stuff you know how to build them
that's the LAT part but you still don't
know what a magnetic field is or how the
magnetic field does it's magic that's
what I'm saying is what physics is about
and that's where I'm at I'm trying to
figure out you know how these things
work and that's what I'm proposing and
if you're interested doesn't mean you
have to believe it all I'm asking is
people understand what I'm proposing
that's all and people confuse belief
with understanding there's two different
things all right I see pineapple is
complaining that I'm not reading the
Super chats no worries I'm getting there
but there is always a priority for those
who use entropy because that is my
priority platform so let's see mr.
Pfister says in recent years there has
been an increase in interest in
microfabricated Mami's device micro
fluidics and the use of PCR for
genetically amplified electromechanical
and electrochemical systems
what does build think is the future for
electronics and embedded systems well I
think you heard it last time I think
we're the last humans on earth so there
is no future for anything period we're
the last humans on earth and I don't
know how you know people don't don't
like that it's a very negative theory to
say hey we're all going to die very soon
and that's my theory I'm saying we're
not going to go into Mars more than
likely it's a possibility but I don't
think we're gonna make it there we're
not going to colonize Mars or terraform
Mars no no that's gonna happen we're
gonna die here in this blue heaven and
so I don't think there's any future for
any new technology I think we're done
with technology essentially we we've
invented what we always want and that's
the cell phone the cell phone is all in
one you have television
have communication you have telephone
you have computer all in one little
handheld carry-on that's it that's the
maximum invention of humans and now we
were ready to die you've heard it there
cell phone and speak civilization
sisters sisters as what is really going
down at CERN what is really going down
now I think they're doing nonsense we
don't we don't need sir
we don't need slack we don't need
Fermilab we don't need any of these at
Brookhaven all these people are
supposedly they think they're doing
theirs think they're accelerating
particles now I work with particle
accelerators okay you know I worked at
many years it's called an ion
accelerator we call them an implant what
you do you create a species you ionize a
gas and then you orient it with magnets
you push it along a beam line and then
you send it to wherever you are and what
they do in CERN you know I didn't work
with Giga electron volt or tera electron
bugs I work with Killough electron volts
thousands of electron volts but the
mechanism is the same and what we did we
accelerated particles and throw them
inside a wafer to give it electrical
characteristics that that was it right
and so I'm familiar with particle
accelerators and all I can tell you is
these people are not accelerating
particles not in the way they think they
are especially when they're talking
about electrons are we accelerating
these beads along the beam line is out
what these people think they're doing if
that's what they think they're doing the
question is okay before you accelerate
the electron before you ionize the atom
what what does the atom look like tell
me why the electron doesn't
spontaneously leave the atom if it's a
little bead right that's rolling around
or somewhere around a nucleus for
example we go with us simplest hydrogen
atom right that's the simplest atom you
have a proton and you have an electron
beam right that's that's the model and
nothing's changed since the days of
Niels Bohr and what's happened we see or
the explanation or the description is
that you
this bead somewhere around the nucleus
somewhere around the prout great the
questions why does the electrons stay so
faithful to the nucleus why doesn't the
electron spontaneously run away why do
we need to force it with some kind of
mechanism to ionize that ad and if you
if you look at one out there no I can
send it to you real quick if you if you
are willing to accept it there I can
lend you this let me send you this this
is a it seems pretty safe to me why the
electron is hanging out around the
proton it is for the same reason that
your magnets were sticking to each other
we just don't know the total reason but
clearly it's never where Khanna's all
right let me check that have you sent it
by email okay it should take a minute
maybe hmm
not receiving anything but anyways what
is the point on if I ever want to if I
ever received the email we can have a
look at the image what was the point we
said it one more time just let me send
it one more time to take a see if that
works
anyways I send it twice then yeah it
shows that it's been sent sometimes
there are delays with Gmail okay this is
this is what I wanted to show you in
there you'll see an atom and an atom
that has not only an S orbital it also
has the p orbital if you've ever seen an
atom if you've seen the p orbital the p
orbital describes a figure-eight that
goes right through the proton through
the center of the atom and we have a
problem here two problems the first one
is that the electron is negative and a
proton is positive and any in
the figure-eight through the nucleus we
got a problem other people just try to
avoid the problem by saying well it
doesn't really go to the new cures or
through the nucleus it gets close to it
because you have this figure 8 described
there and that's the region where you
can find an electron bead a negative
electron P well the issue here is that
you get a negative electron be very
close to a positive proton bowling ball
and the question is why doesn't he get
stuck to it and so they have this figure
age it's going around and you say well
how come it was negative the other ones
positive and positive attracts negative
what kind of atom is that I mean they're
violating all the rules their own rules
to try to get this thing through there
you know to get their description to you
and it's all a violation of their own
rules because if the electron is
negative then it should be stuck to the
positive proton that's one inch the
other one is the orbital itself
what is the orbital what's keeping the
electron tied to the probe where does it
just run away and ionize itself and the
answer is man you gotta force it you
know you got a magnetism
yeah but magnetism is a concept you
haven't told me that what the mechanism
I need to see the mechanism and again
that's why we have to go to objects and
people say well I know Rio through this
with concepts we do it with magnets as
we do it with fields we do it with
energy you know so they introduce
concepts undefined concepts that's the
issue we have no understanding of what's
happening there because we're using
concepts to try to describe rather than
to explain the mechanism that's that's
the point that I'm trying to make all
right Matthew Bertie says what does Bill
think about Karl Marx well that he was
not a physicist in my 20s I read just
about everything from Marx and angles
you know I read a lot of your stuff but
no that's Gorbachev took that away from
me he created glasnost perestroika and
with that you
I thought you know liberalizing the
society was a better deal for me that I
agree with that and not with having this
dictatorship of the proletariat that all
it does really as I seen in several
countries all it does is perpetuate a
new mafia you got rid of the old mafia
now you got a new mafia before you call
the king now you call it what Prime
Minister whatever you call nothing
change you just change one group of
people for another absolutely human
nature comes back
pineapple platypus Emma says Bill do you
like Neil deGrasse Tyson I like one
thing that I heard the other day about
that's about the only thing I liked
about you know and and the fact that
it's black I'm not raised so no problem
there but I like the only one thing that
and he said it to Joe Rogan and he said
you know I don't like tattoos I don't
like to use tattoos and Joe Rogan is
tattooed all over and he says oh you
like you got a problem with me or says
no no I got a reason for it and I liked
his reason he says I don't like to put
you know like carve something in my body
that later on I'm gonna change my mind I
for example you put a swastika right
because you're all for National
Socialists right for example or the
hammering in signal right and then turns
out that you changed your mind
20 years later you got this thing carved
on you say oh [ __ ] huh can I get rid of
this thing
you know I don't believe in this anymore
so he said he likes to leave an opening
to make sure that he's not stuck to one
idea and that he always he wants that
flexibility and I thought that was a
very interesting point from neil
degrasse there may be another reason why
he doesn't like tattoos there is this
story this allegation in the mainstream
media where he started putting his and
up the dress of a woman because she had
ties she had tattoos of Planets
and his excuse is excuses not I did not
put my hand there or I didn't that
raised the dress up word his excuses I
was just trying to look for Pluto and
whether she added tattooed Matthew
Beatty says I'll soon are we going to
die bill how much time well people
always ask that question and that's a
question of religion we have to separate
science from religion when I say that
humans are about to die I'm talking
about science what does that mean by
that I have a theory of how past species
died in mass extinctions and also in
background extinction so there's two
theories and I'm saying we're gonna die
in a mass extinction just like the dinos
just like the Permian synapsids
just like the Triassic archosaurs and so
on we're gonna die just like they did so
all we have to do is figure out what the
mechanism was mama he's concerned about
mechanism trying to visualize how these
animals could have died and I'm saying
they died they all died for the same
reason they died for lack of food that's
the point it's it's the collapse of a
food chain that disappeared and another
food chain continues so you say well
okay how did Mother Nature select
between these guys in that guy and what
it is is this food chain disappears and
the other food chain continues as if
nothing they don't even notice that the
other ones disappeared they just find
Liberty freedom and now they continue
and I'm saying it's it's all has to do
with food chains our food chain is gonna
die because we produce our own food we
produce it only because of money money
is gonna disappear money's gonna be no
more it's not gonna be a depression like
in 1929 it's gonna be a total
disintegration of what we call money
money is gonna have no value whatsoever
no gold no uh
numbers in a computer no bills none of
that all of it disappeared you're not
going to accept money and what's gonna
happen is once money disappears no one
has any incentive to produce food and
deliver it to the cities that's the
mechanism okay whether you believe it or
not that's the mechanism proposing now
when the question that we go back to one
when is an issue of astrology you know I
can't tell you well we're gonna die on
the 12th hour of May 5th in the year
2025 I can't tell you that because you
know I'm not an astrologer
maybe astrologers can tell you I can
talk about astrology all I'm saying is
we're near because I'm saying that the
global economy demands artificial
economy cannot grow forever and at some
point it's gonna come to an end
partly because we're not producing
children children what his children
children is demand so if we don't
produce demand we don't sell if we don't
sell the companies have to close their
shops and the whole thing starts caving
in that's what I'm saying is gonna
happen now when is it gonna happen I
can't tell you allows you stronger I can
only tell you the mechanism it's gonna
be food all right well I'm ready for
this currency disappearance I have my
own plans I don't know if I ever talked
to you about it it's called the cetera
currency the way the celery currency
it's it's a currency made up of salaries
and so you have the advent if you own
all of the fridges you can actually keep
the currency longer and then you can
have people borrow celery and the
advantage is that it doesn't stay fresh
very long and so the currency loses
value within weeks and it disappears and
it's not good anymore so it reflects a
state of the world in complete
decomposition but I would own all of
their fridges doesn't stay fresh I
suggest you put it in the refrigerator
before you eat it then it stays so
that's why I want to owned all of the
fridges to prepare for this moment
Pfister
sister says does Bill think that
Einstein is a bullshitter there's lots
of videos out there and some written
works about understand being a
plagiarist someone who would have copied
the IDs without quoting them correctly
do you do you follow this yeah I think
for example e equals MC squared that's
not ing you had other people before him
that looked at not only that looked at
the special relativity they called it
the relativity theory before Einstein
used the term so so there were other
people right before him that already
dealt with all these issues now why
Einstein got credited with all that he
became a hero he became a celebrity
finance that's human nature we like to
create these celebrities and that's how
I just and went in there but it's
important to know that when Einstein
died with us in 1955 a couple years
earlier he wrote to his friend bezel
basic base of BD SSO and and he told
them look I think all of mathematical
physics is nonsense and he says all of
my theories I think they're just gone
down the drain
I don't believe in them anymore he
became an atheist in general relativity
and what they did he was working at
Princeton and he said all my colleagues
are treating me like an old piece of
furniture I'm here in the corner nobody
talks to me he was isolated like well
he's he's senile you know he he's gone
bananas
this guy doesn't believe in quantum what
do you mean we've proven the problem
right and now he doesn't even believe in
general relativity so they they treated
him like like you know a guy who's gone
bananas and I'd say I think was a little
smarter in that sense I think he
realized that he hadn't explained
anything he still could not understand
how this universe works
so his equations you know like general
relativity if you take his field
equations they can tell you you know the
orbit of mercury much better than Newton
well not much better but a little better
and that's what gave him a little
advantage over new and people embraced
his theory his his proposal why
because they said look this guy not only
has a more accurate equation that tells
you exactly or more after he how mercury
goes around the Sun and these Rosetta's
that it describes but he can tell you
the mechanism the mechanism is the
warpage of space Newton is on record
saying finger non hypotheses he said I
don't have any five pots I have no no
explanation for how the earth goes
around the Sun he was thinking particles
but you could explain with particles so
he said look I'm not even suggesting
anything because I have no idea I can
only give you the mathematical
description
Einstein saying not only gonna have a
better description mathematical equation
mathematical description for how mercury
goes around the Sun but I can tell you
the mechanism the mechanism is the
roulette you have a little ball going
around the ruler that's the mechanism
and there was an added issue there that
people are not always aware because they
don't understand you know what these
equations represent if you look at
Newton's equation you have two masses
and they're separated by distance mass
mass over distance squared right that's
that's the main part of this equation
okay
mass mass distance square so it's two
masses two objects right separated by a
certain distance and that's what he was
applying or what they applied later the
followers they applied to mercury in the
Sun Einstein says something different
I say says forget about mass mass
distance squared that's not what I'm
sange equation is about Einstein's
equation takes a point mass you take the
mass of mercury you put it into a point
you take the mass of the Sun you put it
into a point and now you're gonna
describe the itinerary of the point mass
that's different than say mass mass
distance squared
now you have itinerary of one point mass
those are the the notions of these two
equations that's why they're different
all right the pepper says what are your
thoughts on string theory how our ropes
different from strings
[Laughter]
roben and string have only their names
are similar and people confuse them as
hell all you did was just invent or
reinvent or or just put another word for
string theory no let's get it straight
string theory talks about
one-dimensional lines that string theory
what are those lines made of zero
dimensional points I'm talking about a
three dimensional rope that we can't see
or touch okay we can't see your touch
and you can that's a long story but all
I'm saying is I'm talking about
something physical they're not talking
about anything physical they're saying
they're describing the universe right
and they're describing they're trying to
describe gravity you can't use string
theory to simulate light they're not
describing light they're not describing
electricity they're not describing
magnets as a father working on is
gravity and and that's all that string
theory is a try an attempt to unify
quantum mechanics particles point
particles with general relativity a
continuous sheet of you know space-time
so that what what string theory is
trying to do is saying look if you take
this canvas which we call space-time and
it's got these field equations that
describe it and quantum has on the other
hand these particles and we can describe
the particle world what they're trying
to do is merge the force force the word
force with a word field that's
essentially what they're trying to do
and what they're doing is they're saying
what if we quantize space-time what if
we go in there look very deep you know
we go in there and look at a single
point in space-time that makes up
space-time and we can apply the
equations of quantum mechanics we can
apply Schrodinger in there you know or
or maybe even what's the French guy de
Broglie apply these equations at the
quantum level of space-time at the point
part at the event because that's the
bread and butter of
of general relativity comes down to the
event space-time is made of events what
is a event it's a point in space-time
what if we apply the equations of
quantum mechanics to that point in
space-time that's what Jeff that's what
string theory is trying to do they're
trying to merge general relativity with
quantum mechanics because right now
there is no gravitational theory of
quantum mechanics all we have is a
description at the cosmic level not at
the micro-level T subatomic
that's absolutely lots of people
dreaming of quantizing
spacetime are of space-time in quantum
mechanics in some way but different
branches currently explored I don't know
that there's any that is that has gained
total support pineapple says do we need
more babies well
Bildad already answered on this he does
believe we are not making enough babies
metabeta says tesla versus Edison who
was better better better is opinion and
that's religion they were both inventors
neither one knew what electricity is
neither one knew what magnetism is
neither one knew what an atom look like
all they did was invent they were not
scientists they were inventors they were
that they were engineers they were
technicians they went to the lab they
did a lot of experiments and like the
famous quote by Alva Edison and that
explains it to you very clearly says I
have not failed I have found 10,000 ways
that don't work he tried one thing after
another until he got it right and that
means you don't understand electricity
and you don't need to understand
electricity or magnetism to invent stuff
to develop technology you don't need to
understand what a magnetic field is to
know how and you know to show that a
magnet attracts iron filings you know
that's technology but you don't know how
it's done but you don't care because you
can use the technology that you just
discovered that oh this thing
some metal attracts all these iron
filings oh I can use that for something
you still don't know what's causing that
you don't need to know and that's the
issue these guys did not know Edison and
Tesla they were ignorant as far as
science is concerned they were great
inventors they like to work in the shop
they did a lot of hands-on stuff that's
not science science is you know lay back
smoke a cigar or drink some beer and
think how does Mother Nature run her
shop that's what you need to figure out
in science doing experiments in the lab
and coming up with technology that's a
totally different business that's called
technology all right he brings a
precision to his question he says I mean
who made the better innovations between
Edison or Tesla I don't even know that
the Tesla ever create anything that
became useful oh yeah he created AC
alternate current we owe it to Tesla
Edison lost that fight he was a DC guy
and Tessa won that bout then Tesla also
came up with the Telegraph you could say
and that was fought with Marconi that's
a long story but just to shorten it they
had a fight in court and Marconi won he
got the Nobel Prize and then the United
States government sued him a bunch of
years later like 17 20 years later just
before World War two because the Marconi
company sued the government saying we we
want some money
because you used our inventions during
World War one and the government came
back and said hey no we're not paying
you because those patents were not yours
and it turns out first they gave him to
him saying they're yours here's the
Nobel and when Marconi came back and
said okay give me the money they said no
they're not your patents were not you
there were other people who would better
these things and so we don't know today
who had been and what very interesting
says what does Bill think of the theory
of an ether
an old universe I would the explain its
dimensions if any eternal universe it is
I'm saying that the universe had no
origin no Big Bang nothing like that I
think if you went back a billion years
you would find the same universe
essentially a bunch of galaxies
neighboring other galaxies you go back
another billion or trillion or a
quadrillion years you would find the
same thing galaxies rotating around
galaxies stars within galaxies you would
find always the same thing the universe
is eternal in both directions of time
there was no origin to the universe no
end to the universe and of course this
creates some philosophical problems that
were not used to like we discussed with
my son once who was the first or which
was the first civilization when did
humans arrived for the first time you
know intelligent humans similar to us we
there must have been some in the past
some planet very similar to the earth
gazillions of years ago hm-hm and then
if you go gazillion years before then
because alien years before that at some
point you say well was the first
civilization and we have no way of
imagining this because again we're
thinking about universe that is infinite
in both directions of time there was no
origin to the universe why because
matter cannot turn into space space can
I turn into matter spontaneously or even
with the help of God it's just in part
we cannot imagine something arising from
nothing and nothing turning into
something nothing something turning into
nothing we cannot imagine those who
prosper you don't even believe in the
background radiation background
radiation something else out under the
rope model the background radiation is
the vibration of the ropes that connect
all the atoms in the universe do you
remember you're sending light along
these these ropes and there's gazillions
of ropes and that's vibration we are
able to detect and of course it's got to
be a very low temperature 3 or 3 degrees
Kelvin right so so you're talking a
vibration of background vibration I'm
saying that vibration is either it
we both either or one of the one of the
two right it could be the vibration of
the ropes as Mike goes through them or
it could be the vibration of the atoms
themselves because remember something
here around the earth we have a lot of
matter okay and so there's a lot of
noise here and so if you put something
out there to measure you're gonna
measure something all the time now what
if we could go between two galaxies
where you have maybe 10 to the minus 19
for a fact you almost no matter
whatsoever
what would we also measure 3 degrees
Kelvin if we could measure somewhere
between the two galaxies well I don't
know I don't know if that's the same
environment that we have here close to
the earth so we got a lot of noise here
and to say oh that's the background
radiation is you're not clarifying what
that background radiation is what is
radiation is it just a word of concept I
mean what is vibrating what what
physical object is this radiation stuff
and if you go in there you they'll tell
you well radiation is light is
electromagnetism and that's the Rope
this is what's vibrating you got
gazillions of you know they're vibrating
because they're sending portions along
the rope and if you take the aggregate
of all these ropes well there you have
your background radiation Frank this
advices bill you are always extremely
interesting but answer me this
your expositions are thought-provoking
yet what direct consequence of your
theorem can the West utilize for its
future evolution
well again people think that science is
about doing technology inventing
something what what use can I make of of
your of your discovery science is has no
use no purpose whatsoever so nee has to
do with understanding how mother nature
runs her universe now if you can go in
there and use that the Rope model or the
atom model that I have for some
technology well you know I'm not in that
business at all maybe you're smarter
than me and you're into that business
you want to invent something that's
useful
you say now that bill came up with this
idea maybe I can use it for this -
that's something else all I'm saying is
science itself is is for nothing we have
no use for science other than to
understand how the universe worked what
the mechanisms of the invisible world is
just like you I'm a basic scientist I
cannot get my brain to think of applied
science and care about the opportunities
opened by discovery
I just want to understand the world
alright was there anything else in your
illustrations and what you wanted to
discuss in terms of energy essentially
we covered most of it all I'm saying is
energy is a word that we don't need
because it clouds more than what it
clarifies it's an undefined concept they
treated as an object transfer energy and
so on and it's just one of the words
together with mass time force charge and
fields specifically those that
mathematical physics uses which have no
meaning in physics that is mathematics
because it deals only with measurement
but in and so they applied these words
to relate to the value they get out of
those measurements but we don't need
measurements I don't need to measure how
much force or how much energy of brick
has that broke my window I just need to
understand how the window broke and then
why the glass is on the floor and for
that all I have to say is a brick broke
the window we can all understand that
and that's the way we have to explain
magnetism electricity light etc and
gravity and and so on we have to just
explain baby like kindergarten like how
mother nature runs her universe and
again I'm saying here's a magnet right
it attracts hopefully this is
kindergarten stuff any baby should be
under should be able to understand this
mechanism if we can tell them what
invisible stuff is between these two
magnets that's it you don't need to have
calculus you don't need to know you
don't have to run an experiment here's
the experiment do you want me to run it
a million times to verify it no oh we
need to do is figure out what physical
object is between these two magnets and
we're going to figure out
we need to understand the mechanism and
energy wonderful to get I do have some
silver news that I want to cover alone
but it was a pleasure as always to
interact with you and you're welcome to
the show again in the future
any time bill and his enthusiasm what do
we end up with in terms of the survey is
energy just a bunch of [ __ ]
for people say yes for people say no the
crowd is absolutely split on whether to
dismiss energy as bill does or to be
like me and say well you know energy I
don't think that there was ever the
claim in physics that energy is a thing
that it's an object of physics I think
energy is just a concept and it refers
to our particular universe and how
alright if I have a certain amount of
current in the form of electricity I can
use a motor and the electric motor to
transfer this and to work like that
push and pull and energy refers to given
how much electricity I have how much
work can I get out that kind of stuff
energy is a converter term all right
that is it for the physics part oh yeah
they have